So lady says, "Would I?"...
...and then the guy says, "You hunchback!"
Alright, that's it.
So, welcome to AERA English TV's Native Maestro.
I'm your maitre d', Seita.
And this program is designed to help you become the native maestro.
So, today's Maestro Hook is an American joke.
So, here it goes.
Three men die and they go to heaven. And then God says to the three men,...
..."Depending on how faithful you were to your wife, you're gonna get a good car."
So, to the first guy, "You've never cheated on your wife; you're a great guy,...
...I'm gonna give you a Ferrari."
Second guy, "You know, you cheated on your wife once,...
...so, you know what, what the hell, I'm gonna give you a Lexus."
And the third guy, "Oh you cheated on your wife like five times."
"All you get is a Honda Civic."
But, the guy with the Ferrari is really not that happy.
And everybody says, "How come you're not happy, you got yourself a Ferrari?"
And then he says, "Well, my wife died with me too, but I just saw her in roller skates."
Yup, that's a good joke.
Oh my God!
Alright, so today's Maestro Menu.
That's a good one.
Oh, that's a good one.
And the second one.
Where's the punch line?
So, Maestro Lines.
Oh, that's a good one!
Yeah, it was really funny.
Where's the punch line?
Alright, that's it for today. Hope you enjoyed it.
And see you again on Native Maestro.
Bye-bye!